[Música]
tokio la capital japonesa registró tres
mil 865 casos de curtis 9 el doble que
la semana pasada el primer ministro
yoshihiko gas señaló que el aumento de
contagios no está relacionado con los
juegos olímpicos que avanzan en medio de
la preocupación por los nuevos casos
entre los atletas
el presidente de estados unidos joe
biden anunciará hoy cuatro millones de
trabajadores del gobierno que deberán
presentar el certificado de vacunación o
prueba negativa de kobe 19 importar
mascarilla sin embargo la vacunación no
será obligatoria a republicanos y
demócratas siempre están por el uso de
los estafados
en nicaragua la alianza opositora
presentó su fórmula presidencial a las
elecciones del 7 de noviembre el jefe de
la resistencia nicaragüense óscar
sobalvarro y la extraña de belleza de
nicaragua 2017 berenice quezada se
enfrentarán al actual presidente daniel
ortega en medio de una ola de
detenciones de líderes opositores
[Música]
bienvenidos a una nueva mañana de
información de américa latina y del
mundo mi nombre es lydia valencia
iniciamos hablando de los juegos
olímpicos de tokio porque la capital
japonesa registró tres mil 865 casos de
kobe 19 el doble que la semana pasada
esto al tiempo que avanzan las justas y
hay preocupación por los contagios entre
los atletas sin embargo el primer
ministro yoshihiko señaló que el aumento
de contagios no está relacionado con los
juegos mientras tanto el estado de
emergencia en tokio y okinawa se
extenderá hasta el 31 de agosto la
gobernadora de tokio yuriko koike
aseguró que es importante reducir la
movilidad de los ciudadanos para también
controlar los contagios y para reducir
el número de nuevos casos hablamos de
que es necesario reducir aún más el
movimiento de personas con el objetivo
de alcanzar el mismo número que en el
momento de la anterior declaración del
estado de emergencia
johana 7 ya necesita
hablando ahora el medallero en la
jornada de hoy la judoca brasileña mayra
aguiar se colgó de nuevo la medalla de
bronce de la categoría de los menos 75
kilogramos en unos juegos olímpicos
después de haber logrado de al tercer
escalón del podio en londres 2012 y rio
aguiar de 29 años consiguió la sexta
medalla de brasil y la segunda en el
judo después del bronce que consiguió
daniel harding en menos 66 kilogramos
por su parte la francesa madeleine
malonga ganó su primera medalla de plata
y le dio a su país la décima medalla en
los juegos de tokio
vamos ahora eeuu el presidente de job
aiden anunciará hoy oficialmente que
cuatro millones de trabajadores del
gobierno deberán presentar certificado
de vacunación o prueba negativa de ccoo
y 19 y portar mascarillas los casos de
coronavirus siguen aumentando en el país
a causa de la variante delta y además se
vive un enfrentamiento entre los
demócratas que promueven el uso de la
mascarilla y los republicanos que lo
rechazan
regresa la atención al capitolio esta
vez por cuenta de un viejo debate que ha
vuelto a la primera plana el porte de
mascarillas los centros de control y
prevención de enfermedades recomiendan
portarlas
incluso a aquellos que han sido
vacunados cuando se encuentran en
espacios cerrados la mayoría demócrata
de la cámara baja impuso el uso de las
mascarillas en el recinto una decisión
de rechazada por los republicanos
estamos vacunados no somos un poco de
contagio pero nos obligan a llevar
mascarilla no en el senado pero si en la
cámara esto se trata de un mayor control
esto es sólo el comienzo porque las
escuelas van a volver a funcionar y las
van a cerrar de nuevo y se trata de
control base monos en la ciencia los
comentarios del líder de la minoría
republicana de la cámara y llevaron a
nancy pelosi a referirse a él como un
imbécil según los centros de control y
prevención de enfermedades el 67 por
ciento de los condados de eeuu tienen
altas tasas de transmisión del virus lo
que ha llevado al presidente by the end
a insistir en la necesidad de la
vacunación
no descartar imponer que las inyecciones
sean obligatorias para empleados
federales algunos estados se han
adelantado como por ejemplo nueva york
que requerirá vacunas a los empleados
estatales además de ofrecer incentivos a
los ciudadanos when you get your first
those al recibir la primera dosis contra
el coronavirus taxi
al recibir la primera dosis recibirá un
incentivo de 100 dólares one hundred
down 100 dólares para cualquier
neoyorquino que acuda a un centro de la
ciudad para vacunarse y packs de más de
160 millones de personas han sido
completamente vacunadas en eeuu aunque
la vacunación sigue siendo eficaz contra
la variante delta nuevos datos
científicos indican que incluso los
individuos vacunados pueden ser
contagiosos
vamos a colombia porque en el norte del
país muy cerca de la frontera con panamá
se vive una crisis migratoria miles de
extranjeros están a la espera de
continuar su paso hacia estados unidos
mientras necoclí que el pueblo donde
están acampando colapsa la información
en la tiene maría clara calle
más de 10.000 migrantes están estancados
en el norte de colombia concretamente en
el municipio de necoclí un pueblo de tan
sólo 40.000 habitantes nunca antes
habían llegado tantas personas a esta
costa que suele ser el lugar de paso de
africanos asiáticos y latinoamericanos
los migrantes son tantos que están
asignados en las playas esperando tomar
un bote por las aguas del mar caribe
para luego intentar atravesar la difícil
selva del darién llegar a panamá y
continuar su camino hacia el norte esta
vez la mayoría son haitianos yo pido a
la autoridad colombiano que mete mano a
ver cómo después en el grupo que están
acá y que espera que reciben otro grupo
eso lo único que yo pido en enero de
este año el pueblo colombiano también se
desbordó cuando miles de migrantes
quedaron atrapados casi el cierre de las
fronteras a causa de la pandemia pero
esta vez es diferente porque no hay un
cierre forzoso y la cantidad de
migrantes pone en jaque la capacidad
sanitaria y económica de necoclí un
pueblo azotado históricamente por la
guerra y la pobreza preocupada porque se
nos puede presentar en estos momentos
una calamidad bien sea de salud pública
o un brote más venimos en confinamiento
del cob y la situación es tal que el
gobierno local de necoclí declaró
calamidad pública los migrantes están
atrapados porque los traficantes a los
que les pagan sólo transportan una
cantidad de personas insuficiente frente
a los cerca de 1.000 extranjeros que
llegan cada día su mayor aspiración es
encontrar un país que los acoja
en nicaragua la noticia es la fórmula
presidencial más reciente y es que
después de la detención de siete
precandidatos el partido opositor
ciudadanos por la libertad designó sus
candidatos justamente a la presidencia y
la vicepresidencia para las elecciones
de noviembre en las que ariel ortega
busca su cuarto mandato consecutivo los
detalles también con maría clara caché
un ex comandante de la contrarrevolución
y una ex reina de belleza esa es la
nueva fórmula presidencial con la que la
oposición nicaragüense quiere plantarle
cara al mandatario daniel ortega en las
elecciones de noviembre
óscar sobalvarro será el candidato
presidencial de ciudadanos por la
libertad partido del que es
vicepresidente en sus tiempos de guerra
fue comandante en la guerrilla de
derecha resistencia nicaragüense
washington financió para combatir a los
sandinistas estamos convencidos de que
un pueblo unido depositando su voto con
la misma valentía y decisión con el que
reclamando su libertad en las calles es
más fuerte que cualquier voluntad
totalitaria la fórmula vicepresidencial
será premisa que sal a la señorita
nicaragua en el reinado de 2017 y de
quien no se conocía su activismo
político hasta ahora
si se puede porque de nosotros depende
el cambio de cada uno de ustedes de cada
una de las personas que me está viendo
en su casa de nosotros depende que
nicaragua cambie estas son algunas de
las últimas cartas políticas del partido
pues de los 7 precandidatos
presidenciales arrestados en nicaragua
en los últimos meses tres se habían
inscrito con la alianza de ciudadanos
por la libertad la mayoría han sido
acusados de ser traidores a la patria en
total 29 opositores han sido arrestados
daniel ortega sigue abriéndose paso de
cara una posible cuarta reelección
barriendo no sólo con contenedores
políticos sino también con quienes
critican su gestión la asamblea
controlada por los sandinistas canceló
el estatus legal de 24 ongs incluidas 15
que cuestionaron el manejo de la
pandemia por parte del gobierno el nuevo
presidente de perú el izquierdista pero
castillo anunció que enviará al congreso
un proyecto de reforma constitucional el
anuncio tuvo lugar este miércoles
durante su discurso de posesión sin
embargo se prevé que la iniciativa se
encontrará con un
el camino en el parlamento donde la
oposición cuenta con la presidencia y
con la mayoría
así finalizamos ustedes pueden continuar
con más de nuestra página web france24
puntocom para ampliar la información
internacional nos vemos más adelante
[Música]
france24